shroud is back our lord and savior has
returned to the competitive scene but
this time it's not to his land of
counter-strike it's to play valorant
with sentinels we've had a weekend to
let this marinate but honestly there is
a lot of important stuff we need to talk
about
we need to talk about shroud
[Music]
all right guys you know the drill i need
to like subscribe and ring that
notification bell for me thank you all
right before we get into the video to
make sure that you guys can see my
appropriate attire the uniform is on
you're ready to go
okay so first what you saw on friday and
over the weekend is not bait
he's back
i'm back baby
trout is returning to the pro scene to
play valerie competitively and no he's
not going through the open qualifiers
and he didn't put out an lft he's
playing with the n.a titans the giants
sentinels today.esports reported that
sources said zelsis is set to join tens
shazam dapper and shroud to complete
sentinel's full lineup
[Music]
oh my god yeah i know i'm aware this is
insane
and honestly the sentinels who put this
out on friday before the weekend y'all
suck but in all honesty well [__]
played boys i did not see this one
coming
and neither did tense is that real
yeah shroud is gonna be our fifth going
into lcq yes that is correct is there a
timeline where i saw this happening no
[__] way but holy sh it's not a joke
not a meme it's actually real i'm sure a
lot of you guys already understand but
let's go through why this is such a big
deal if you've seen the story of shroud
or the story of shroud 2.0 you'll know
that shroud is a csgo living legend he
has seen many successes and is regarded
by many to be one of the best to touch
the game of counter strike almost looked
like skadoodle had actually come out on
top there what a flick coming in trout
getting one of the headshots he's
tapping away shroud could he do it again
he's up to 11 kills and looking for
number 12 are you kidding me shroud
four kills can anyone take this man down
most famous first time on cloud nine
shroud has seen a lot of success in his
career that esports pro today dream of
but he retired he became an immensely
popular streamer so popular they took a
deal with the now defunct mixer to move
over to their platform after a mixer
died he took the bag and went back to
twitch to stream full-time we've seen
him compete in balor before under what's
going on but the team never really made
a dent unless you're calm who remembers
everything and how those games went
shroud will be playing in the na lcq
instead of sick who is taking a leave of
absence we've talked briefly about the
role the main role that i want to be is
controller on most maps there is a world
and where i might squeeze into another
role but here is why this is a big deal
shroud has the experience he has the
firepower he has the brain power he
understands the game really well and
beyond all of this
it's [__] shroud it is an insane
return that no one saw coming it shocked
the world one of the literal faces of
counter-strike is now competing
invalorant it could have been anyone
we've heard whispers of a lot but shroud
oh that was sick i enjoyed that that was
good
wait is it
or is he uh as a content creator to come
out of a pretty cozy retirement to play
a game that you said you weren't going
to play professionally not that long ago
that's a pretty big deal being a
professional player in any video game is
so inconsistent that it's so just
mentally taxing because
if you're somebody who
has like a pretty big brand
in the game
that that doesn't help your case you
know one question a lot of people were
asking was why
one could be cynical and say there was
money involved but shroud is famously
loaded this whole thing was
spur of the moment over dinner like hey
sentinel needs a fifth
do we throw your name in there and i was
like absolutely like i'm itching to i'm
itching to try competing again and found
something new and i want to see how i
can fare against something that's new
rather than going back to what i already
know now my lovely the score esports
viewers and shroud fanboys welcome i
don't mean to dampen the mood but there
is more to this than meets the eye
beyond a cool announcement video
sentinels will be playing in the lcq
their last chance to qualify after and i
say this both as a journalist and a fan
not performing at all but meanwhile
teams like ghost gaming who went 4-1
made it to playoffs didn't win anything
but overall performed better than
sentinels
are not able to compete in the lcq but
sentinels will be competing after not
making stage two playoffs and with a
formerly retired player who has not seen
stage time in years teams make roster
changes all the time do not get me wrong
but even as a sentinels fan
it's enough to make me pause and i'm
going to be honest with you mr shroud
hearing in your announcement video that
you're going to try hard is great yes
that is the first thing that i would
expect from you i do not doubt that you
will try hard but to hear in that same
announcement video that this was a spur
of the moment decision that you have to
figure out how this team plays and that
you have talked about your role briefly
alarm bells are going off you're playing
in the lcq boys it's time to put up or
shut up you've got our attention now
we're all watching another thing is that
there are certain points being made by
people that sentinels are actually using
this as an attempt to lock in
franchising which is looming over
everyone's shoulders people are saying
that sentinels don't have to really
perform well for franchising that this
roster move is enough to do it which
ethically is kind of
but regardless of all of this
shroud is playing with senals and that
is a hell of a sentence to be true i
guess na is just really living up to the
storied esports saying
expect the unexpected
[Music]
colton i hope you enjoyed me doing a
k-pop dance for everyone while danny was
talking because there's a song called my
bag from by g idol i was like all right
five diamonds in my bag
danny's okay